Hello, my name is David Haas,
and in my previous presentation,
I explained to you how cryo-cooling was invented
and has contributed substantially
to the field of structural biology.
And now, I'd like to give you an example
of an actual benefit that was derived from that,
which is the HIV epidemic
and some of the drugs
that were developed through structural biology.
Once again, we need to thank Max Perutz,
who began the field of structural biology
and had the great vision
that three-dimensional structures
not only permit the identification
of how the molecules act in living organisms
but in fact how the structures can be determined,
as well as how drugs can now be designed
using the process called structure-based drug design.
So, now I'd like to tell you a story
of how I have experienced
"science for the benefit of humanity."
While I was at the Cold Spring Harbor Laboratory,
I was told
that my cryo-cooling experiments and publications
probably advanced structural biology
by 10 or 20 years.
And at the time, you know,
10 to 20 years of scientific discovery
is really usually not a big deal,
and it didn't have any significance to me...
until while I was preparing for a presentation this last April,
at the Protein Data Bank in Rutgers,
they asked me to talk about exactly what I'm telling you:
the invention of cryo-crystallography.
And while I was doing that,
I discovered the AIDS epidemic
and the Lazarus effect.
And for those of you who don't know
what the Lazarus effect is,
in medicine, the Lazarus effect
is when many people are dying
and then some event occurs
where these vast numbers of people stop dying.
And that's exactly what happened
with the AIDS epidemic in 1996.
This diagram here is from the United States
statistics from the CDC.
But let me just tell you first about the worldwide AIDS epidemic,
which began in 1980.
There have been 76 million people who have been
infected with HIV virus since 1980,
of whom 39 million have died.
And today, worldwide,
there were 37 million people still infected.
There is no cure for AIDS,
as you know,
but there is a therapeutic treatment,
and that's what I'm gonna explain.
So, now if I can talk about the United States,
this is the death curve and the infection curve.
The red one's the infection occur
for AIDS in the United States.
So far, since 1980,
700,000 Americans have died from AIDS.
And as you see,
the curve begins in 1980
and continually increases,
with hundreds of thousands of individuals
becoming infected with AI...
with HIV virus each year.
Since the average lifetime,
if you had caught HIV in...
during the '80s,
was typically 2-4 years,
your statistics would move from the red curve to the blue curve,
which is the death rate,
in about 2 years.
And you see that the death rate is continuous
from 1980 to 1996.
It's a straight line, basically,
which means that none of the drugs
-- and there were many drugs that were tried --
produced any effect on the death rate.
In 1984,
the HIV virus was identified as being
the causal agent of HIV.
And then, in 1986,
proteins were isolated,
one of which is this protein,
which is HIV protease,
one of the enzymes that makes the HIV virus.
The crystal structure was actually determined,
the three-dimensional structure, in 1989.
And we can thank Merck Laboratory in New Jersey
for not only solving the structure,
but they published the data to the whole world
in the Protein Data Bank in 1989.
This gave the opportunity
for hundreds of other laboratories
to work on the HIV protease.
It turned out that inhibitors
were actually made,
and they were made using structural biology,
using cryo-cooling.
And in 1996, the therapy was introduced.
It was this cocktail of three drugs,
of which the HIV protease inhibitor was the most important.
And instead of dying, you would...
you would live a normal life,
with in fact...
it was called a manageable disease.
And because of that,
the individuals did not transfer to the death curve,
and you see this precipitous fall
in the death curve in 1996.
The death rate fell from 96%
down to below 20%.
So, you can just imagine,
between 1980 and 1996,
if you had become infected with HIV
and you went to your physician,
and he would tell you had a 4% chance of surviving.
But in 1996,
you would go in to... go to your doctor,
and he would say, yes,
today there's a therapy.
You will not be cured of HIV,
but it will in fact become a manageable disease.
And this dramatic fall in the death rate in 1996
is called the Lazarus effect.
Tens if not hundreds of thousands of Americans
lived who would not live.
And basically, the HIV protease inhibitor drugs
which were developed
were developed years and years faster
than they would have been
if there had not been structural biology,
and as it turns out, cryo-cooling,
which participated in that.
So, it makes me feel very good
that, literally, my research, done 50 years ago,
not ending up in dusty pages in a journal
but actually saving thousands of lives.
That really is science for the benefit of humanity.
Experiments that you do,
and publications that you make,
as a young scientist,
will in fact... could contribute very much to the future.
So, I hope you've become a little bit inspired
with the work that I have done,
and the fact that it inspired me,
and maybe it will inspire you to continue.
Thank you.